i feel like managing artists is like
kind of like a blanket statement a lot
of people make in terms of like yeah i
managed an artist or i do a r [ __ ] or
okay give me kind of like
if you're an artist manager what are
your tasks like what is like define that
for me
you have to you have to enhance the
situation whatever they have going on
like so a lot of times people come up to
you and be like hey i need management
and i'm like you don't really have
anything to manage yet you know i'm
saying there's no demand there's no
deals to make there's no interest
there's no
revenue that need to be brought in so
you don't need a manager and i'd
probably
assess their situation and tell them
what they do need right a lot of people
don't need management to get to a point
where there's something to manage
so
but so essentially you're just
putting gasoline on whatever fire's
already yeah and you're using your your
your leverage and your relationships to
take it to another level like if you
come to me and you're seven my job is to
make you a ten you know what i'm saying
maximize and build your talents and give
you my tutelage and show you the way to
be a the best artist you could possibly
be a manager is like a bridge to your up
to other side of your potential you know
what i'm saying so you might be making a
hundred thousand a year a month let me
show you and do these things with so we
could maximize that and now we're making
500 000 a month you know what i'm saying
give you a bunch of strategies and a
bunch of disciplinary tools to get to
where you need to go but at the end of
the day it's the artist and the talent
that is the driving the ship you know
what i'm saying i'm just kind of like
siri that's got you got you is it you
know what it's crazy too because dealing
with artists it's not a magic button
people think managers are a magic button
like it's also well i think what what it
is is what some people [ __ ] up is they
get a manager and then they stop doing
the work that's not it that's what i'm
saying the artist is the car
the manager is the gps the gps make this
road smoother lead you to the right way
guide you you know you're going to track
now this is the way we need to get to
where we need to get to or show you
exactly like some people don't even have
a plan for this so so i'm going to show
you
where you and your talent can get you to
and this is the way we need to do it to
get to this part you almost want um
an artist who kind of self-manages as
well
if that makes sense yeah 100 because
something i i mean like i've seen it
where there's like people who
they really need their hand held through
every little step of the way and every
artist is different some people need a
little more handheld than others some
people are totally self-sufficient and
some artists are like
you know they need they call it the
morning yo get up you know you have a
thing today or your flight his itinerary
some people i could just shoot the text
and like yo i'm on my way there and the
artist might be like i'm there already
you know what i'm saying so yeah so you
just play it by i guess you just kind of
play it it's a la carte there's no one
managing style that fits every artist